welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition aka
morgan freeman and this video we're
breaking down the teaser trailer for
dune
it's just dropped online and throughout
this video we'll be going through the
ins and outs of it
and discussing everything you need to
know about the movie there may be some
spoilers here
so if you want some surprises for the
movie then i highly recommend that you
go off world as fast as you can
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos that will spice up your life
and don't forget to hit the thumbs up
button if you enjoy it
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so i just want to preface this by
saying that i actually got to catch the
trailer early in cinemas when it was
shown in front of tenet
i've been sitting on this video for a
while and as of its release i'm actually
away in york
so if the trailer has some more added
scenes to what i saw in the cinema
then i can't add them in or break them
down if there is i'm sure that people in
the comments will drop a lot of extra
info
so make sure you go there if we miss
anything out that being said
i already know quite a lot about the
film so even if we do miss a couple of
things with the extra footage
they'll probably be covered here anyway
but yeah i'll be covering it all in a
future breakdown if there is
just let definition have a day off yeah
cheers
thank you now as for the teaser trailer
itself its centers predominantly around
the gamja bar test
this scene actually opens the novel
itself and it pretty much
instantly lets us know what kind of
person that paul is
in case you don't know the gomja bar is
basically a test of humanity
that's used to determine someone's
intellectual prowess
the test involves placing your hand
inside a box that causes immense pain
and you must demonstrate your cognitive
abilities
by not withdrawing it the pain would
cause animals to pull their limbs away
instinctively
and by holding your hand in place even
though it's agonizing
it shows that you can consciously make a
decision to endure something
aware that the other outcome is death
but what is this death
exactly well we see a needle placed at
paul's neck
and gomjibar is actually the name of the
lethal poison
that's placed within this in the book
the test isn't referred to as the
gumdubot test
rather it's just called a test however
over the years in the fan community
it has picked up this name though you
can just also call it the test
now in the film and the book it's held
by the reverend mother gaius helen
moheim
mahaim is an ancient and old wise woman
that's carried out the test several
times to see if people
are truly human or not in the book we
learn that no one that she's ever tested
has managed to undergo as much pain as
she inflicts on paul
and this shows how determined of a
person that he is now in the trailer we
see a lot of literature that surrounds
her
and this hints at to just how
knowledgeable that she is i don't want
to spoil too much
but yeah she's probably gonna play into
the story in a big way
and i think that it's great that they
set her up early on with what will
probably be one of the tensest parts of
the movie
the scene was also shown in the 1984
film and similar to that the character
asks paul to place his hand inside the
box
as it burns away at it if you haven't
seen the movie and don't have the time
to read the mammoth saga before december
then i highly recommend that you check
it out as it should get you up to speed
with everything
we also see a lot of shots of arrakis in
the book arrakis is described as one of
the most valuable planets in the entire
universe
because it's only on this planet that
one can find
spice spice is the backbone of
civilization in the empire
as it's created a system of commerce
that allows life to exist
spice is actually a drug and it can give
the user a longer lifespan
heightened awareness and also unlocks
pre-science
in some humans pre-science is a psychic
ability that
coupled with the other things brought on
by the drug can make someone almost
godlike
the small shots of arrakis that i saw
made it look absolutely stunning
and it's clear they're going all out
here with the visuals as pretty much
everything in the trailer looks
astounding these dunes stretch as far as
the eye can see
i expect to see them a lot which is why
the movie is called
june look i told you i told you we
weren't gonna miss anything
now we also see an ornithopter
ornithopters are basically the most used
form of transport in the imperium
they're pretty much just like cars for
the characters of the movie
and they're what i imagine they'll be
using to get around the most
now paul steps off of one so we do know
that he'll be using one in the film and
we also see a shot in which he and his
men
stand in their armor looking over the
desert plains this looks brilliant
and we have a lot to talk about here in
terms of who the characters are
firstly oscar isaacs is playing duke
lito atreides
the duke is actually paul's father and
he's married to lady jessica
played by rebecca ferguson the pair
ruled the planet of kaladin together
and they tried to steer paul in a
certain way through their parenting
now in an interview with entertainment
weekly the cast did discuss
what the plot of the film was going to
be and how these two characters would
become integral to paul's journey
according to the interview the duke and
his mother have taken the character from
his lush
scandinavian scandinavian-like homeworld
to preside over the spice extraction on
arrakis
in the film they're attacked by
criminals and the characters then have
to defend themselves from that point
onwards
the director also explained the role of
paul's mother and said that
she had sort of jedi mind trick powers
and could control people through her
voice
she's very much someone that can
manipulate the balance of power in the
universe
and because of this she's highly sought
after however
she isn't an easy person to take down
and when casting the role the studio
wanted a warrior priestess
rather than a nun lady jessica's duty is
to deliver a savior to the universe
and is likely that paul will take up
this mantle she's training him along
with his father
and they wish to bring peace once more
to a galaxy riddled with war
josh brolin is playing guernie halleck
who's a skilled fighter
that becomes a high-ranking member of
the group over the books
originally played by patrick stewart he
can kindly tell from that casting
what type of person he's going to end up
being not to jump too far ahead and get
well very very spoilery but after the
death of the duke
which happens far in the future don't
worry i'm probably won't be in this
movie
it is hinted that he and lady jessica do
become lovers
again that's just suggested and i highly
doubt that the duke's death will happen
at any point in this film
so i don't feel too bad for ruining it
but anyway heavy
heavy spoilers and all that now jason
momoa
is also playing duncan idaho idaho has
almost cat like reflexes
and because of this he's a very skilled
fighter
you also see javier bardem still got
remove his face mask
in order to speak to someone he's joined
by zendaya's character
and the rest of the fremen these become
integral to the story as they ally
themselves with paul
and his forces and we do catch a glimpse
of him walking alongside the group
now whilst these are all good characters
that go to arms with one another
we also see baron vladimir this
grotesque villain
is being played by stellan skarsgard and
yeah
he's a really really bad guy the baron
is immensely
fat and he actually has to have
anti-gravity devices
known as suspenses which support his
weight so that he can move
the baron is very clever and he wishes
to wipe out the atreides once and for
all
and take over arrakis in the teaser i
saw
we did catch a glimpse of his head
emerging from a vat of strange liquid
but yeah let me know below if they added
anything to this
by the time this video gets released i
have seen the trailer but you know let
let my past self know know how much of a
schmuck he was for taking a day off
now we also see dave bautista and he's
playing the beast
this hulk of a man is extremely powerful
and
intimidating he's so ruthless that he
killed his own father and you can also
expect to see some big confrontations
with him in the movie
we also see chang cheng as dr wellington
you
and sharon duncan brewster asleep kinds
liek kines is a planetologist that was
actually the secret leader of the
freeman
so expect her to work in the shadows
fighting for the good of arrakis
now this was actually a gender swap for
the character which has some fans
annoyed
but personally you know what i'm quite
excited to see what happens with them
and lastly is the score itself which is
composed by han zimmer
from the brief snippets that we get i
think it sounds
absolutely incredible zimmer is one of
my favorite composers ever
and i think he's the perfect choice for
the futuristic film
zimmer has already shown that he can
handle other worldly things with
interstellar
and i can't wait to see what he brings
to the table
anyway that's everything we caught and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it too so make sure you comment below
and let me know like i said
a thousand times there could be things
added to what was in the theaters
but hopefully this video covered enough
that it went over everything that was
added anyway
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of neil's timeline and tennis
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over his full journey so
definitely check it out if you want to
know more
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the winner is going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of august
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content
early then please consider clicking the
join button below you can also come chat
who's on a discord server linked in the
description
or heavy swirlies on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'm off to enjoy york
take care much love good night
[Music]
foreign